-I'm Steve Higgins, and we're
about to play "Pup Quiz."
-Oh, yeah!
♪♪
-Playing tonight, we have
the host of "The Tonight Show,"
Mr. Jimmy Fallon!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And from "The Big Bang Theory,"
the lovely Kaley Cuoco-Sweeting!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And this is the first puppy
up for grabs...
Mr. Gary Frick Jr.
-Aww.
-Here's how the game works.
I'll be asking both of you
animal trivia questions.
If you answer correctly, you win
a golden retriever puppy.
If you answer incorrectly,
your opponent gets the puppy.
-Oh, my God.
I can't take it.
-The most puppies at the end
of the game...
-That's the cutest dog.
-...wins.
-Oh, my God.
-Aw.
Oh, my doggy. Aw.
-Kaley, you're our guest,
so you'll answer
the first question
and see if you win or lose
Gary Frick Jr.
"Please don't lose me."
Kaley, what breed of dog
is Scooby-Doo?
A, German shepherd,
B, a bloodhound,
or, C, Great Dane?
-Great Dane.
-Great Dane, that is correct!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ah!
-You win Gary Frick Jr.!
-Oh, good dog?
-The score is 1-0.
Alright, the next question
for you, Jimmy.
Which of these birds...
-Ooh, I'm great with birds.
-You are?
So you've given
many people the bird?
-You got a Scooby-Doo question.
Yeah. Here we go.
What bird is what?
-Yeah, hello.
Which bird is native
to New Zealand?
A, the whooping crane.
B, the rough-faced shag.
-Uh-huh?
-Or, C, the brown trembler.
Boy, take a selfie, right,
with that one.
-[ Laughs ]
-You will never get this.
-I'm gonna say
the New Zealand --
It's a trick question here.
I think it's gonna be
the brown trembler.
-The brown trembler.
That is wrong!
[ Buzzer ]
-Yes!
-It is the rough-faced shag.
And Mary Kennedy goes to Kaley!
-Oh, my gosh.
-Oh, my --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh!
Look at those puppies.
-What? What?
-What?
-What'd you say?
-I said,
"Look at those puppies."
-No, Higgins.
Higgins, Higgins, Higgins.
-Oh, do you hear that sound?
[ Dogs barking ]
That means it's time
for Double Puppardy...
-Did you hear that sound?
-...where the questions
are worth two puppies.
-Did you hear that sound?
-Oh, how cute.
-Kaley!
-No, you didn't hear the sound,
did you, little schmoopy-poopy?
-Kaley.
-Yes?
-In 2008...
-Oh, God.
-...what animal was knighted
by the king of Norway...
-If you get this -- Come on!
-...for distinguished service
in the Norwegian Royal Guard?
Was it A, a "si-lion"?
B...
-Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
-...a horse.
-Sea lion.
-Oh, sea lion.
-Oh, A, sea lion.
Oh, I see.
Was it a sea lion?
Got it.
Thank you.
-Yeah, no problem.
-B, horse, or C, penguin?
-It's just --
It's got to be a horse.
-Is that your final answer?
-Yes.
-Ooh, that is wrong!
It is a penguin!
Jimmy wins Kyle McAdams
and Lisa Armstrong!
-Hi!
-♪ Double puppy ♪
♪ Double puppy ♪
-Hi, guys! Yeah!
Hi, hi, hi.
-Oh, my God.
-Oh, hi, buddy.
Hi. Oh, my God.
They smell like puppies.
-They do! They do! They do!
-They smell like puppies.
Oh, my gosh, guys.
You're so much better
than those other puppies.
-Oh, my God.
-So much better.
-Alright, Jimmy,
this question is for you.
-Oh, my God.
-Which of these
recording artists
does not have a species
of wasp named after them?
[ Laughter ]
Which of these recording artists
does not have a species
of wasp named after them?
Is it A, Shakira,
B, Madonna,
or C, Lady "Guh-ga"?
[ Laughter ]
-I think it's "Ga-ga."
-Gaga? I'm sorry. C, Lady Gaga?
-Wasp.
-I don't understand
the question.
-Madonna could be a name
of a wasp, right?
-Two of these people have wasps
named after them.
One does not.
-Shakira doesn't sound
like a name of a wasp.
Oh, maybe it does.
-One of them
does not have a wasp.
-I think Lady Gaga
would not have a wasp.
That would not be
a name of a wasp.
-Is that your final answer?
-Yes.
-Well, then you're wrong!
-What?
-It is -- Madonna does not
have a wasp named after her.
-What, does she have a bee
named after her?
I mean --
Oh, my goodness.
-Roger Blaine
and Ted Mooney, get out here!
-Oh, my gosh.
-This -- I could die.
I could die and just --
This is it.
This is it for me.
[ Dog barking ]
-Oh, my God.
-Kaley.
-Oh, my goodness.
-This is for two more puppies.
-I can't talk right now.
-In 1947, what type of animal
became the first
to be launched into space?
-What do you think it is,
schnoody?
-Was it A, a rhesus monkey?
-Schnoopy?
-What do you think?
-B, a fruit fly?
Or C, a golden retriever?
Launched into space, 1947?
-Do you think
it was one of you, schmoopy?
-1947.
-What do you think?
Oh, I love you, too.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yes.
I have to answer now.
Oh, it's got to be you.
Okay, it's you.
It's the golden retriever.
It's got to be
a golden retriever.
-Is that your answer?
-Yes.
-You are very much wrong.
It was a fruit fly!
Jimmy, you get Fred Winston
and Michelle Anderson!
-What?
-Yeah!
-Michelle Anderson?
What a name.
-That's Michelle.
-Michelle Anderson.
-Hi, Michelle Anderson.
Fred Winston.
Come here, Fred. Hi.
-Oh, Fred.
-Oh, my goodness.
Look at these guys.
Hi, guys.
-Oh, you know what?
[ Dog barking ]
That sound means it's time
for Final Puppardy.
-You keep hearing the sound
before the sound happens.
Very interesting.
-I'm prescient.
I know when the sound is coming.
That sound means it's time
for Final Puppardy.
This is for all your
opponent's puppies and the game.
-No!
[ Laughter ]
-Pick up the boards and markers
next to you.
-Guys, stop eating
the microphone.
-Here, I'll help you out.
There you go.
You'll write down the answer.
-Don't worry, you guys.
-Whoever's closest...
-Sorry, dudes.
-...to the correct answer
is the "Pup Quiz" champion.
-Don't worry.
-Here is the question.
-Okay, got you.
-Don't worry, babies.
Don't worry. You won't have to
go to Uncle Jimmy Fallon.
-How old was the oldest
goldfish that ever lived?
You have 10 seconds
starting now.
[ Dogs barking to tune
of "Jeopardy!" theme ]
-How old was the oldest goldfish
that ever lived?
-[ Laughs ]
-Ow. Ow!
-He bit you?
-You bit me!
Oh, my God.
Am I bleeding?
-Did you write anything down?
-Am I bleeding?
-Boy, he gave you a hickey!
-He gave me a hickey.
-Oh, my God.
-He really bit you!
-He did, huh?
-He really got you.
Here, I'll take him if you want.
-I see your answer, 42.
-Oh!
No, I didn't!
-How old is the oldest --
-Oldest goldfish ever to live?
Alright, Jimmy,
what did you write?
-20 years old.
-I put 42.
-Ooh, the correct answer is 43.
Kaley, you are the winner!
[ Bell dinging ]
You win all the puppies!
-How would you get that?
-Thank you! Oh.
-Guys, our thanks
to Kaley Cuoco-Sweeting
and all these adorable puppies.
-Ben Affleck!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, all of our puppies...
[ Audience awws ]
tonight have dressed up
as their favorite superheroes.
[ Audience awws ]
-Whoo!
-And this is the first puppy
up for grabs.
In the role of the Batman
himself, it's Gary Frick Jr.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey, buddy.
-Here's how the game works --
I will be asking you
trivia questions
based on animal things.
And if
you answer them correctly,
you win
a golden retriever puppy.
[ Audience cheers ]
If --
-Based on animal things?
-Yes, animal things.
-Things.
[ Laughter ]
-You answer them incorrectly,
your opponent gets the puppy.
Now, most puppies
at the end of the game
is the "Pup Quiz" winner.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, Ben,
since you're our guest,
you are up first --
this question is for you.
-Okay. All right.
-In the DC comic series --
-Oh, forget it.
[ Light laughter ]
-What was the name
of Batmine's -- Batman's canine
crime-fighting partner?
Was it --
A, Rex the Wonder Dog,
B, Ace the Bat-Hound,
or C, Batdog?
-[ Breathes deeply ]
I -- You know, I'm just going
to go with Batdog.
-Batdog. Judges?
No!
-No!
[ Buzzer ]
-It was Ace.
-Ace.
-Ace. The Wonder Hound.
Jimmy, you win Gary Frick Jr.
-Oh, no!
-[ Chuckles ]
[ Applause ]
-Wow!
-He's Batman.
-Aww!
-That's got to hurt.
-It stings.
That was in my wheelhouse.
-That stings.
-Yeah, yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
I should have --
-How do you like them apples?
-...one of the specials now.
-Jimmy,
next question is for you.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-Which one of these birds --
Which one of these birds...
-What?
-...is native to the forests...
-What? Are you kidding me?
-...of South America?
-What?
[ Laughing ] How did he --
-Is it...
-What?!
-...A...
-He got,
"What's Batman's dog called?"
-...the shaft-tail finch...
-I don't know.
-...B,
the white-bellied bustard,
or C, the purple honeycreeper?
Which one?
Just take a guess.
It's not this bird.
[ Laughter ]
-Which one of these birds
is native --
-Jimmy, this is a bird --
it's not this bird.
-Yeah, I know.
I'm not looking.
I'm not --
I'm not looking on purpose.
[ Light laughter ]
All right. Yeah, thank you.
[ Clock ticking ]
Hmm.
-Shaft-tail finch.
-Well, you know, well,
I used to vacation
in the forests of South America
and...
[ Light laughter ]
I remember always using --
take my --
I would take my binoculars down.
-Yes.
-I would take my -- put my --
cover my flask of buttermilk.
-Yes. You always get
warm buttermilk,
wherever you go.
-That's correct.
And I go, "Honey, look
at the white-bellied bustards."
-Really?
That's what you would say?
-That's what I'm saying.
-No! It was
the purple honeycreeper.
-I brought my own --
-Oohh!
I brought
my own white-bellied bustards.
That's the --
-Ben wins Kyle McAdams,
who's dressed as Superman!
-[ Chuckles ]
-Hey, hey.
-Oh, wow.
[ Applause ]
-Aww.
-[ Laughs ]
-How ironic.
[ Dog barking ]
Oh! You know
what that sound means?
It's time for Double Puppardy.
[ Laughter ]
-Whoo!
-Questions
are now worth two puppies.
-Oh. Come on, buddy.
-And the next question
is for Ben.
-All right.
-In 2013, what type of animal
did scientists prove
has a sense of rhythm,
making it the first non-human
to keep a beat?
Was it -- A, an orangutan,
B, sea lion,
or C, crow?
-I'm going to go
with orangutan.
-You would think.
It's a sea lion.
-Oh, God!
[ Buzzer ]
-Jimmy, you win Mary Kennedy
dressed as Wonder Woman
and Ted Mooney
dressed as The Flash.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my goodness!
-Oh, my God.
This is unbelievable.
-Wow.
-Look at the puppies.
-Flash.
-Come here.
-♪ Wonder Woman ♪
-Alright.
Wonder Woman goes here.
-There you go.
-Flash.
Here's The Flash, right there.
-Alright. Next question
goes to you, Jimmy.
[ Audience awws ]
-Oh, no, a secret identity --
-Secret identity.
[ Light laughter ]
Batman. Oh, my gosh.
Batman, come here.
Sorry. It --
-Sorry --
-Wait a second.
Bruce Wayne? What?!
-You're giving it away!
-You're ruining it for everyone!
-I'm not ruining it.
No, sorry, all right.
-Jimmy, this question
is for you.
-Yes.
[ Light laughter ]
-With more than
2.4 million followers,
who is the most popular dog
on Instagram?
-Oh, okay.
I think I've met this dog.
-Is it -- A, Marnie The Dog...
-No.
[ Light laughter ]
-...B, Doug The Pug....
-That's a made-up name.
[ Light laughter ]
-...or C,
Maru Taro The Shiba Inu?
-Dude, definitely, it's got to
be Maru Taro The Shiba Inu.
Right?
-Yes!
-That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You win Michelle Gordon
as Supergirl
and Lisa Armstrong as Batgirl.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's get them out here!
-That's alright. Wonder Woman.
-Wow, you are
swimming in puppies.
-Wonder Woman. Mary.
[ Chuckling ] Oh, my. My.
[ Light laughter ]
Oh, yeah. Oh, my gosh. Oh.
-There you go.
-Alright.
Do you have any Shiba in you?
[ Dog barking ]
Would you like -- Oh!
You know what that sound means?
-What's that?
-It's time for Final Puppardy.
[ Laughter ]
This is for all your opponent's
puppies and the game.
This is for the win, Ben.
You can win.
-Wonder Woman's all over me,
man.
-It's all on this one.
-Oh, my God.
-I can still do it.
-My God.
-I can still get there.
-He can still...
[ Light laughter ]
-Ready?
-Get your board.
Get your board.
You're gonna write down
the answer to this question.
Who's ever closest
to the correct answer
is the "Pup Quiz" champion.
-That's great.
[ Laughs ]
-Roughly how many dogs live
in New York City?
[ Audience ohhs ]
You have 10 seconds,
starting as of right now!
It's more than six, 'cause I see
six puppies here now.
[ Light laughter ]
Somewhere between
six and infinity.
How many?
[ Buzzer ]
♪♪
Okay.
[ Drum roll ]
Jimmy, what did you write down?
-10 million?
-10 million dogs.
[ Light laughter ]
That's a lot of honking dogs.
Ben wrote down 2 million.
The answer is...
600,000!
The winner is Ben Affleck!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Take some of these off, please.
-[ Laughs ]
Go ahead.
Take a couple of them.
-Well, that is --
that's not a puppy.
-Our thanks to Ben Affleck...
-I want all these dogs!
-...and all of these
adorable puppies.
-Drew.
-Yes.
-You are our guest,
so you shall start.
The first question...
-Okay.
-...will either win or lose...
-[ Sighs ]
-...Gary Frick Jr.
[ Audience awws ]
-Gary!
-Which of the following is not
a real hybrid dog breed?
The Schnoodle, the Schweenie,
or the Schnar-Pei?
[ Light laughter ]
-[ Sighs ]
-What do you think?
For Gary Frick Jr.
-The Schweenie.
-You say the Schweenie?
Ooh, that is wrong.
[ Buzzer ]
It is the Schnar-Pei.
-No!
-Jimmy.
-The Schweenie?
-You get...
-Aww, hey, buddy.
-...Gary Frick Jr.
-Aww. Puppy.
[ Dog barking ]
-Next question is for you.
Oh, look at him.
-Yeah, he loves me.
-Next question is for you,
Jimmy.
-Okay.
-Which of these birds is native
to the mountains
of Northern Thailand?
[ Light laughter ]
-What?
-Which of these birds is native
to the mountains
of Northern Thailand?
-I'm so glad you're here.
-You're the last puppy
I'm gonna see.
-Is it a, the bufflehead...
-Uh-huh.
-...B, the robust woodpecker,
or C...
-It's pronounced "woodpecker,"
not wood--
-...the giant nuthatch?
Which one is it?
-Stop it. I mean...
[ Laughter ]
My fingers are very delicate.
So be careful.
[ Laughter ]
He's bit-- Someone's biting.
[ Dog barking ]
Stop it. Stop it.
He's bark--
[ Dog barking ]
-Oh.
-Hey.
His name isn't Gary Frick.
His name is Cujo -- this dog.
[ Laughter ]
All right,
I'm going to say the...
-Bufflehead?
-The rhino, yeah.
I'm gonna say
the robust woodpecker.
I don't know.
-The robust woodpecker, no!
[ Buzzer ]
It's the giant nuthatch.
Drew, you get Mary Kennedy.
[ Audience awws ]
-Aww, hi.
-Aww.
-Come on. What's up, Gary Frick?
-I do know that there's
a pygmy nuthatch, though.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
[ Dog barking ]
-Oh, that sound means
it's time for Double Puppardy.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-Questions are now
worth two puppies.
-Oh.
[ Light laughter ]
-Speaking of two puppies,
Drew...
-Yes.
-Hey.
-...what species of animal...
[ Chuckles ]
-Uh-huh.
-...does the male give birth
instead of the female?
-Oh.
-Is it -- A, the seahorse...
-It's the seahorse.
-...B...
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, come on.
-Is that your final answer?
-Yes.
-Yes, it is!
Kyle McAdams, Lisa Armstrong,
get out here!
[ Dog barking ]
-Wow.
-Oh, Kyle McAdams
is one of my favorites.
-Double puppies, dude.
-Thank you.
-Come on. Oh.
-Three to one.
[ Dog barking ]
Oh, my gosh!
You know what that sound means.
-What?
-It's time for Final Puppardy.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Chuckling ] This is where
whoever answers this question
gets all the puppies
and then some.
[ Laughter ]
-When does it get weird that
I'm letting them lick my ears?
[ Laughter ]
-All right,
grab the boards next to you.
-I think they crossed the line.
-Okay.
-You're going to answer.
[ Laughter ]
You're gonna write down
your answer.
-Okay.
-Closest
to the correct answer...
[ Laughter ]
-Thanks, buddy.
-There you go. You got it?
-Yeah.
-Yes, yes.
-[ Chuckling ] Okay.
-Ready?
How many pounds
does the average --
and I'm saying average --
blue whale weigh?
Not a fatty blue whale
or a thinny.
[ Light laughter ]
Average blue whale.
♪♪
That's who's in charge of FIFA,
isn't it?
♪♪
Ready?
Time's up.
Everybody ready?
-I don't know. Wait.
Yeah, all right,
I'm just going to go for it.
-Really? That's
what you're going to write?
-Down.
-All right.
[ Laughter ]
All right, Jimmy.
What did you write down?
-5,000 pounds?
-5,000 pounds.
Average blue whale --
5,000 pounds.
Drew?
2 tons, which is pretty much
5,000 pounds, isn't it?
[ Laughter ]
-Is that...
-How much is a ton?
Is a ton 2,000 or 2,500?
-2,000!
-2,000.
So the winner is Jimmy because
the correct answer
is 300,000 pounds!
[ Bell dinging ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Jimmy gets all the puppies!
-Ah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
Oh, hi, guys.
Aww. Thank you so much.
-Come on.
-300,000.
Oh, my gosh. 300,000.
I was trying to think -- the
average whale where I hang out.
Hey, puppies.
All right, thank you, Higgins.
You guys,
thanks to Drew Barrymore.
[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]